Public Sénat en partenariat avec le
Centre national du livre vous présente
au bonheur des
[Musique]
livres quel bonheur bonjour de retrouver
une émission littéraire nous sommes avec
agè de s agè bonjour le livre s'appelle
le Château des Rentiers publié aux
éditions de l'Olivier c'est votre 16e
livre et Clément guiss vous êtes donc
romancière et Clément guiss le passant
du berie voici donc le livre au seuil
Clément est rédacteur en chef adjoint à
aim le monde et il a été à Libération
c'est votre deuxième livre je crois
queimment vous avez consacré un livre
donc à Vadim personnage phénoménal à qui
vous avez rendu hommage agès nous allons
commencer par vous les gens vont dire
durant ettimbré parce que quand quand on
regarde les deux livres on se dit c'est
pas une émission littéraire on est
immobilier je ne suis pas durant je suis
Stéphan Plazza avec tous les défauts que
je peux avoir le Château des Rentiers
c'est une sorte de biographie collective
que vous avez voulu euh à partir
justement de ce quartier du 13e
arrondissement le quartier welbéquen les
tours et ça commence par les
grands-parents ouais euh puisque mes
grands-parents habitaent au 194 r du
Château des Rentiers dans une tour ces
tours qui ont germé dans les années 70
en détruisant ce qu'avait été le 13e
arrondissement enfin pour mes
grands-parents c'était bien ils ont
réussi à se payer un petit de pièces ils
étaient bien contents mais ils l'ont pas
fait tout seul ils ont dit à la plupart
de leurs amis d'acheter avec eux ce qui
a fait qu'ils ont vécu la fin de leurs
années comme dans une coloque géante h
ce qui est je pense assez souhaitable ce
qui est amusant évidemment dans Château
des Rentiers c'est que ça n'a rien un
château il y a pas le moindre rentier à
l'horizon et quand la jeune de Sart
passe dans ce quartier elle se dit au
fond c'est c'est vraisemblable que les
gens puissent dire paris est une ville
merveilleuse parce que franchement le
13e arrondissement dans cette manière
d'être
reconstruite cette ville c'est
absolument atroce h j'avais beaucoup de
mal à comprendre parce que c'est vrai
que moi j'avais grandi dans au milieu de
maison ouvrière enfin entre mes 0 et mes
5 ans que tout a été rasé et on mais des
tours sans harmonie
c'était je sais pas comment ça a été
concerté ou si ça a été
concerté mais
c'était c'était àre et nous on sortait
pas tellement du quartier et c'est vrai
que j'entendais cette phrase la plus
belle ville du monde et je regardais
autour de moi je disais ah bah ça doit
être vraiment moche ailleurs hein alors
ce qui est intéressant dans le livre
d'aniè maintenant on va rentrer dans le
vif de sujet c'est c'est un livre sur la
mémoire alors il y a plusieurs façons de
raconter à la fois le communisme la
déportation cette famille qui qui est
une famille juive vous la littérature
l'enseignement l'adolescente que vous
avez été tous ces âges de la vie on se
dit elle va écrire une SAG monument ment
genre Guerre et Paix bien pas du tout ça
fait 200 pages pourquoi parce que vous
avez adopté la
méthode Montaigne qui est la méthode
assaut et agambad c'estd que ce sont de
courts chapitres où vous passez d'un
registre à l'autre totalement ouais
c'est un livre très hybride et très
libre c'est peut-être le plus libre de
tous les livres que j'ai écrit et à
chaque fois
que que un chapitre se terminait celui
d'après n'était pas avait pas de de lien
nécessaire en fait finalement il y a un
lien entre tous et il y a un fil qui est
tendu mais je voulais me donner
l'autorisation d'utiliser toutes les
formes de narration possibles la
narration classique le dialogue le
témoignage la réflexion sur vous-même
parce qu'à un moment vous dites mais
vous vous posez des questions au cœur du
livre si la mémoire est bonne vous vous
dites mais qui ça va intéresser un livre
sur la mémoire et sur les vieux c'est
despouvoir vous vous posez la question à
vous vous racontez l'histoire des
grands-parents et puis après P vous
plongez vous-même à 6 ans à à 17 ans
vous avez votre période Annie Lenox ou
dur mix avec les cheveux comme ça et et
tout défile et après on change
totalement de registre vous veneez
agréger l'enseignement ouais mais comme
comme c'est enfin en tout cas dans ma
tête je sais pas comment c'est dans la
vôtre mais tout coexiste essayez pas de
fouiller ça va être dangereux mais tout
coexiste c'est-à-dire toutes les
personnes qu'on a été pour moi elles
sont pas elles ont pas disparu elles
elle continue d'être là en tout cas
mentalement et donc je voulais faire un
un un livre qui rend
euh qui qui rendre cette impression
qu'on a
euh visible tangible presque tactile
d'être à la fois ce qu'on est maintenant
mais ce qu'on a été et avec aussi la
présence de nos souvenirs qui arrivent
par flash sans prévenir euh qui nous
envahissent ou qui nous rassurent et de
ce point de vue-là c'est un livre pour
moi qui est un livre très réaliste sur
ce qui se passe à l'intérieur d' tê
votre sourire d'ailleurs qui va avec le
livre que cette idée de la mémoire de la
vieillesse de la multiplicité justement
des parce que vous avez aussi une bande
d'amis vous allez voir une banquière à
un moment pour lui demander d'emprunter
de l'argent pour essayer de trouver une
sorte de falanster vous allez pouvoir
tous vous installer rien de tout ça
n'est morbide en fait il faut être en
forme pour vivre dites-vous ouais c'est
ce que je fais dire à ma grand-mère
parce que en fait l'avantage aussi c'est
que dans ce livre euh il y a il y a pas
mal de gens qui parlent il y a moi mais
il y a y a la banquière il y a comme
vous dites il y a un architecte mais il
y a aussi les morts qui viennent qui
viennent vient qui participent à la
narration si là ma grand-mère qui à un
moment dit que il faut être en forme
pour être grand-mère mais en fait il
faut être en forme pour vivre tout court
et et le livre il est parti de là en
fait il est parti du fait que je m'étais
rendu compte le temps avançant que ça
devenait un tout petit peu plus
périlleux de s'envoyer dans dans
l'avenir de faire des projets de
euh ailleurs la banque vous le rappelle
assez bien en vous disant ben non
maintenant vous pouvez pas vous pouvez
plus emprunter ou alors il faut vous
presser bientôt vous ne pourrez plus ce
est amusant c'est que la banquière vous
dit moi mon rêve dans la vie c'est
d'accompagner un projet d'artiste alors
que vous êtes écrivain donc artiste et
en fait elle vous emmerde le plus
possible pour essayer justement
d'accompagner ce projet alors j'ai lu
dans le Dictionnaire amoureux des
écrivains d'aujourd'hui que vient de
signer Frédéric bbéd que vous étiez l'un
impératrice du prolepse alors qui est
une figure rhthorique le prolepse ça
sais pas à vous qui est agrégé je vais
apprendre ça il consiste à se projeter
dans le futur pour parler du présent et
pour revenir peut-être éventuellement
dans le passé ouais ben impératrice du
problè c'est la première fois que j'en
ai une devant moi et ben j'étais pas au
courant mais mais c'est vrai que c'est
une pratique que j'ai dans l'écriture et
dans la vie et le principe de ce livre
c'était justement de pouvoir continuer à
se projeter y compris vers des choses
qui sont pas
euh enthousiasmante euh donc on se rend
bien compte quand on avance en âge que
les que les les possible se rétrécissent
et je vais pas apprendre à faire la roue
demain par exemple je pense pas que
c'est une très bonne idée euh mais il y
a des T chos concevez strictement aucune
mélancolie vous pour le lecteur pas du
tout l'idée c'est l'idée c'est de
trouver un moyen d' de d'avoir une
anticipation heureuse mais c'est c'est
une construction mentale pour des choses
qui ne sont pas particulières
bah par exemple votre maèire qui
témoigne à la Fondation Spielberg parce
qu'il est question quand même de la
déportation des gens qui ont disparu
alors tout ça é évoqué h il y a un petit
côté Woody Allen dans le ton parce qu'on
a l'impression d'une certaine forme de
guté même quand il s'agit de de tragédie
et et c'est surtout cette forme j' j'y
reviens qui donne au lecteurs l'envie
d'avancer d'avancer d'avancer tout au
long du livre parce qu' cours de
chapitre en chapitre ah bah tant mieux
si si vous le dites mais moi c'est c'est
comme ça que je l'ai écrit aussi
c'est-à-dire que euh que il fallait que
tout soit que tout aille dans ce sens-
là dans dans le sens d'une exaltation
malgré tout enthousiasme malgré tout et
il y a un moment une une phrase que je
cite qui est qui est un un comment un
proverbe Racidi qui dit il faut
s'efforcer d'être joyeux ce qui n'a rien
à voir avec
d'ailleurs c'est présent aussi dans la
sous une autre forme dans le livre de
Clément guiss le droit au bonheur dans
la dans la Constitution américaine et le
bonheur et la joie sont pas du tout la
même chose mais c'est forcé d'être
joyeux en général ça ça couvre un
quelque chose de très dur et de en fait
c'est une façon de vivre les tragédies
aussi voilà et d'ailleurs cette phrase
magnifique page 195 il y a rien de plus
ridicule que le présentateur d'émissions
littéraire qui lit c'est pour ça qu'on
est ravi d'avoir mis des citations
certaines insomnies demeurent en nous
ell transfigurent la nuit donc c'est à
la fois justement un livre joyeux mais
en même temps c'est un livre qui est
parfaitement conscient de ce qu'est la
vie c'est-à-dire une tragédie euh je
vous cité une phrase de Sagan de mémoire
elle disait le passé nous réserve des
surprises est-ce que c'est un sentiment
que vous avez aussi ah mais oui c'est
très bien oui parce qu'on on est c'est
pas mal Françoise et ben oui elle est
pas mal Françoise parce que parce que il
il se il se
recompose au fur et à mesure qu'on va le
visiter on a des on a des morceaux du
passés qui sont pr présents en nous sous
la forme de souvenir récurrents et
cetera mais en vérité quelque part tout
est enregistré mais on y a pas forcément
accès et parfois en écrivant en
fouillant ou en tirant sur le fil d'un
souvenir on trouve des choses qu'on ne
savait pas savoir et ça c'est la
surprise alors le l'autre grande qualité
nous allons passer à clémenguis pour
honneur des livres du livre d'agè alors
je vais prendre des comparaisons qui
sont extrêmement laudaties ça va faire
un peu flag Horner pour une première
émission littéraire mais vous racontez
vous-même que vous êtes désingué parfois
par les critiques littéraires que dit la
pauvre de Sart elle écrit très mal parce
qu'elle a pas suffisamment souffert
celui-là il va se reconnaître forcément
c'est le côté Einstein je disais Léonard
Bernstein Bernstein quand il quand il
jouis les symphonies de malheur il
faisit exprès quand ça lui plisait de
faire traîner allemand est qu' trouvait
ça beaucoup mieux que la manière dont ça
avait été écrit et Einstein la dilution
du temps bah c'est exactement la méthode
de Sart quoi et c'est un peu ce qu'on va
retrouver avec Clément qui vous
accompagne c'est un livre sur la beauté
le Château des Rentiers le voici aux
éditions de
l'Olivier mon cher Clément vous vous
avez découvert c'est un autre registre
sur la mémoire un trésor de la culture
américaine c'està-dire un immobble on
reste dans l'immobilier comme je disais
on n plus donc au château des entier qui
est un immeuble donc downtown New York
am manatan donc qui est 222 Bowery le
bowy encore aujourd'hui c'est le
quartier pour simplifier et parler
clairement pour les gens qui nous
regardent le plus pourri de New York
depuis des années le quartier des gangs
c'est le bout de Chinatown et là donc le
le jeune Clément Guis enquêteur si l'on
peut dire découvre un immeuble qui a
joué un rôle gigantesque que dans le
développement de la littérature
américaine de la peinture américaine de
la poésie américaine comment ça s'est
fait ça s'est fait cette découverte
entre guillemets de cet immeuble elle
s'est faite d'abord par la la lecture de
l'autobiographie de ce grand poète
américain qui était John journ voilà
grand poète et artiste visuel qui avait
été l'objet d'une très belle exposition
pais de Tokyo compagnon d'Hugo rondinon
donc artiste suisse vivant grand artiste
aussi ça c'est voilà j'ai j'ai lu cette
autobiographie dans laquelle il
racontait comme ça qui s'est installé
dans cet immeuble tout début des années
60 et j'ai un petit côté un peu
obsessionnel un peu furteur et je me
suis mis à chercher et j'aime beaucoup
voilà passer des heures à chercher à
traquer des noms que je connais pas sur
internet à regarder dans des bouquins et
cetera et je me suis rendu compte que
absolument tout le monde était passé par
cette adresse j'exagère un peu mais de
Marc rovco à Deb Harry de kifaring à
William burose évidemment qui a vécu une
dizaine d'années voilà et il y a deux
catégories pardonnez-moi il y a ceux qui
ont carrément habité donc vous faites la
liste au départ c'est effectivement
rotco phénoménal Michael godberg qui lui
a succédé alors ce qui est incroyable
dans cet immeuble c'est qu'au départ
c'était un immeuble ma chère agès qui
avait été conçu par les riches
Américains d'town qui voyant la
délinquence proliférer en bas avait
voulu faire une sorte de d'institution
sociale là-dedans il y avait un gymnase
et rotco donc à la fin de sa vie
cherchant un endroit un peu comme une
sorte d'église pour pour pour construire
ses grands tableaux sublimes commandés
par sigram Ben va s'installer dans le
gymnase il va fermer les fenêtres il va
en regarder deux il y a ceux qui sont là
et il y a ceux qui passent là passe là
tout le monde tout le monde c'est tout
New York je me suis amusé à faire des
listes d'invités def ça m'a beaucoup
amusé de faire un peu voilà comme une
voilà et tous ces gens-là sont venus
tous ces gens-là ont passé des nuits
entières ont passé des des soirées des
conférences des performances euh oui là
vous êtes pudique hein je suis pudique
parce que les perform sexe allez
allons-y carrément nous sommes sur
Public Sénat j' partous partout sén non
mais les amours de John Jorn d'ailleurs
qui célèbre continuellement le rôle
fondamental de l'homosexualité le rôle
aussi tragique du sida à l'époque tous
les grands peintres américains sy tomble
Robert rchanberg Jasper Jones étaient
tous homosexuels et vivaient ça dans
cette communauté donc ont tous couché
c'est ça qui m'a amusé avec ce
personnage incroyable qui était John
journ ils sont tous tous passer par cet
immeuble par le lit de J j ça m'a amusé
aussi de de comprendre comment cet art
américain avec lequel on a tous grandi
comme une espèce de de mythologie
absolue qui moi en tout cas me
bouleverse depuis l'adolescence en fait
elle avait été dans sa réalité la plus à
la fois banale mais aussi la plus belle
dans cet immeuble où on retrouve donc on
retrouve Jager on il y a une scène
absolument phénoménal parce que alors il
faut dire Clement que cet immeuble
appartient à un
monsieur qui encore une fois pourra être
un personnage de Woody Allen il
s'appelle Sam wapnovitz voilà wapnovitz
il a appartenu à ce personnage qui était
un honnêtement un personnage qui m'a
bouleversé quand je suis tombé dessus
qui était un un petit commerçant qui
avait acheté la la la boutique du
rez-de-chaussée et puis qui a racheté
ensuite tous les étages parce que ça
valait absolument rien qui ne
connaissait rien à nalar qui était du
descendant d'une famille juif biélorusse
qui qui travaillait 23 heur par jour
aussi ce que vous avez en commun tous
les deux he parce que vous dites à un
moment j'ai l'impression d'être
ukrainienne dans votre livre agès et là
on retrouve les mêmes origines c'est
l'Europe centrale celle de abolument et
donc cette cet homme s'est mis à
héberger des artistes et lui qui ne
connaissait absolument rien à l'art a
sans doute été l'un des plus grands
bienfaiteurs de l'ARN York avec une
espèce de passion
bouleversante il recevait comme ils
avaient pas d'argent il le payait
parfois en tableau et lui les gardé
précieusement mais sans aucun esprit de
spéculation sans aucun esprit de de de
prétenion juste par amour pour C cette
vie qui était a-dessus de lui et qui qui
le qui le transportait alors pourquoi il
faut lire le livre de Clément parce que
nous sommes dans une émission littéraire
et donc nous sommes là pour célébrer la
beauté vous avez évidemment Williams
burrow donc la
révolution de la poésie américaine John
journ on poursuit la révolution de la
poésie américaine vous avez de très
nombreux peintes je vais pas les citer
tous mais on en a parlé on a parlé d'un
certain nombre à un moment d'ailleurs
warall qui a eu plusieurs factories à
trois adresses différentes va envoyer à
Sam une sorte de tombau ou plutôt de de
brouettes de tableau à lui pour acheter
l'immeuble Sam ne voudra pas le faire le
destin de l'immeuble aujourd'hui il
existe il faut le dire il est prês du
New Muséum mais il y a un personnage
central et on a une évidemment avec
toute l'équipe de bonheur des livres on
vous a réservé une surprise phénoménale
à tous les deux qui va nous rejoindre
dans un instant il y a un personnage
central aprèsfement léger c'est Marc
rotco qui est là euh jusqu'à la fin de
sa vie et qui va et qui va donc faire
ses tableaux archicélèbres qui sont à la
tête moderne donc à Londres aujourd'hui
Marc rovco trouve dans ce le gymnase
donc de cette ancienne auberge de
jeunesse déjà l'idée est folle l'idée
est incroyable le en gros le le
brouillon on va dire de son rêve qui est
de construire un espace total habité par
la peinture habité par la lumière habité
par les formes un peu comme ça ce
plateau il il trouve dans cet
espace voilà l'écin de cette reg cette
belle phrase quand on est né Marcus
rotcovid sujet du SAR un sale petit juif
détesté tous c'est qu'on est devenu un
citoyen américain un peintre applaudi on
peut croire à tout et pourtant il
s'enferme Clément c'est qu'il le fait
exprès il a une commande de 6 g qui est
une famille de Canadiens qui ont fait
fortune dans la prohibition qui leur
demande pour leur immeuble magnifique
pour leur immeuble luxueux de faire des
peintures pour la salle de pour la salle
de restaurant d'un hôtel il commence à
travailler il accepte la commande c'est
après tout un homme qui a besoin de
travailler VO et puis je pense qu'il se
rend compte que ces toiles sont
peut-être un petit peu trop bien si
j'ose dire pour orner un restaurant et
lui qui a une vraie
vision on va dire de gauche mais en tout
cas de
oui une idée de l'art quand même
politique contrairement à ce qu'on
pourrait penser de l'art abstrait ça le
dégoûte l'idée que ce soit des peintures
qui deviennent de simple décoration pour
des restaurant ou où où on mange des
steaks à 100 dollars et donc il va il va
refuser la commande au dernier moment et
ces toiles là sont aujourd'hui des
merveilles qui sont à la tête et au
Japon et C voilà d'ailleurs vous parlez
parce que il il se promène pas mal rotco
pour aller en Italie je sais pas si vous
aimez l'Italie agès mais en Italie à un
moment il est sur conversation avec un
personnage qui croise il vérifie qu'il
ne connaît rien à l' qu' ne connaît pas
de marchand de tableau qui n'a jamais vu
un artiste de sa vie et cetera et cetera
et il lui fait la confession qu'il ne
fait pas ou qui n'a jamais fait
évidemment ass commanditaire notamment
la famille sigram c'est-à-dire l'AB le
fait d'aborer de l'idée que ces tableaux
qui sont quasiment religieux puissent
finir effectivement au bord de steak
frit ou de hamburgers et dit même je
crois qu' veut donner envie à ses fils
de de vomir voilà de vomir leur je
l'ai pas dit c'est vous et tout à
l'heure je lirai un poème de de John
jour à la fin quand tous les gens seront
couchés car le moins qu'on puisse dire
c'est que c'est un poème qu'il a lu
justement au Palais de Tokyo quand on
lui a rendu hommage à 80 ans et qui
donne bien l'idée de ce que pu devenir
justement la poésie américaine et cette
révolution je sais que vous aimez rodco
agès je sais que vous adorez la musique
toutes les rockstars sont passé dans ce
222 B mais public sdin est une chaîne
qui adore vous faire des surprises voici
en exclusivité le fils de Marc rotco qui
va nous rejoindre et qui est donc l'un
de ceux qui a permis cette exposition
magnifique qui va se dérouler donc à la
Fondation Viton à Paris pour l'un des
plus célèbres peintes du monde Marc
rotco il a même écrit un livre que voici
voici Christopher
rotco voilà le grand plaisir de recevoir
donc avec agès et avec Clément
Christopher rotco voici le livre
Christopher bonjour bonjour bienvenue
dans Au Bonheur des livres vous êtes
évidemment co commissaire de cette
exposition consacrée à votre Père qui
est l'une des plus plus importante
rétrospective qui eu jamais lieu la
dernière c'était la tête moderne il y a
des années au Musée d'Art moderne de la
Ville de Paris il y avait une exposition
rotco avec une queue phénoménale qui
allait du musée donc à président Wilson
jusqu'au-delà du pont de l'ALEM et voici
ce livre l'intérieurité donc à l'œuvre
qui est la manière dont vous expliquez
l'œuvre de votre Père qui est un des
peintres les plus importants on le sait
donc du 20e siècle y a quelque chose qui
m'a beaucoup amusé al je vais parler
lentement parce que vous parlez français
euh et donc nous allons continuer en
français à un moment Antonioni voulait
voulait rencontrer votre papa parce
qu'il disait au fond moi je ne filme
rien et vous vous ne peignez rien donc
on va
s'entendre c'est c'est Anton qui a dit
ça ça ouais oui ils ont ils ont
rencontré les deux à Rome en
1960 si 6 je crois et mais mon père qui
a a insisté que en fait ces tableau
étent rempli de de de de contents des
des idées mais en en PH photiquement il
a l'apparence d'être plus ou moins vide
je suis sûr que le même vrai pour les
les films de Antonioni le désert rouge
par exemple les magnifiqueoui c'est le
meilleur voilà euh alors Christopher
pour beaucoup de gens euh votre père
incarne le sublime euh votre père
incarne la condition humaine avec des on
a l'impression moi je vais vous dire ce
que je pense mais c'est vraiment très
modeste
euh on a l'impression que la d'abord ces
peintures gigantesques sont la
quintessence de la culture américaine
d'une certaine manière parce qu'elles
sont très grandes mais très intimes et
qu'elles incarnent quelque chose de de
fantastiquement gay par leur couleurs
mais en même temps c'est la condition
humaine c'est que c'est presque un art
dramatique est-ce que j'ai raison ou
est-ce que je suis complètement idiot
absolument je crois que tout je crois
que tout dit que les les tableaux
contient presque tout mais il il sont il
a vut que le que il peut parler
directement à à l'âme de chaque de ses
c'estes spectateurs et il parle en
langue plus ou moins universelle c'est
c'était le son esprit son son souhaite
et mais c'est c'est un langue d'émotion
m très humaine donc à cause de cela il a
il a
essayé parler des des plus grandes idées
dans les les quelquefois dans les les
tableaux grands et quelquefis dans les
tableaux petits mais toujours rempli des
des morchons et d'esprit de
corp l'esprit de l'esprit humain Clément
marcco s'est
suicidé je sais que Christopher n'a pas
beaucoup envie de parler euh des
affaires personnelles de son père bon il
était il il était malade on lui avit
demandé de faire des tableaux plus petit
euh donc overdose Barb biturique et puis
donc on l'a
retrouvé donc ayant mis fin à sa vie ce
qui est très émouvant actuellement à
Paris c'est que vous avez une exposition
de Marc rotco vous avez une exposition
de Van Gog vous avez une exposition de
Nicolas de Stal les trois donc ont mis
fin à leur vie quand cette vie est
devenue absolument impossible est-ce que
agès vous aimez Mar rotco énormément
ouai parce que là j'ai montré tout à
l'heure on montrera les livres mais bon
ces œuvres absolument sublimes euh
pourquoi vous qui aimez le jazz vous qui
aimez ma Davis la lumière pour la
vibration h euh la présence du noir qui
ressemble qu'on pourrait associer à la
présence du silence chez milvis par
exemple qui disait que son écriture
musicale c'était beaucoup à partir du
silence et là le noir qui est là mais
qui n'est pas là mais qui est toujours
là hm hm euh ça donne une vibration
unique à à la couleur et ça c'est très
spécifique et Clément vous racontez dans
le livre que justement les tableaux euh
du père de Christopher sont les tableaux
qui quelquefois sont avec de multiples
couches euhh mais quelqueesfois aussi
des tableaux qui sont euh beaucoup plus
légèrement par elle est pure ouais
presquei que presque ouis presque
Aquarel presque aquarelles que je trouve
très impressionnant dans vous connaissez
d'ailleurs on se connait ce que je
trouve très impressionnant dans l'œuvre
de rovco et j'ai très hâte de voir
l'exposition notamment pour ça c'est que
c'est c'est un pain dont on a envie de
s'approcher on a c'est vraiment la
peinture absolue au sens où on a envie
de regarder de près de regarder de loin
et je trouve qu'il a un autre peintre
dont on a envie à la fois de tout voir
le le détail mais la vision d'ensemble
c'est Turner et rofco est turn enfin RKO
adoré Turner je crois et je trouve de
cette cette idée à la fois du du
millimère carré et du du mtre carré moi
qui me fascine chez rovco alors le livre
de pas dans le motif voilà absolument il
faut savoir que rodco a une période
qu'on pourrait qui ressemble au
surréalisme comme beaucoup de peintres
abstraits américains qui sont passés
justement à l'abstraction mais qui au
départ étai des gens influencés par par
exemple le Chinien Roberto Mata ou par
maçon donc influencé par le surréalisme
mais la grande idée Christopher que vous
défendez concernant votre père c'est que
c'est la même chose c'est-à-dire que la
première période de votre père et celle
qu'on connaît plus maintenant c'est la
même idée qui court toujours et quelle
est cette idée oui c'est c'est l'idée
que il vousut parler de de la condition
humain et que il veut diriger notre
notre attention par la silence
à de des des questions plus essentielles
existential c'estàd pourquoi pourquoi
nous sommes ici pour est-ce qu'il y a un
Dieu qu'est-ce que le mort euh c'est
inévitable et est-ce qu'il y a de du du
sens là est-ce qu'il y a plus euh c'est
les idées qu'il qu'il pense nous que
nous pensons de ces idées tout le temps
mais il y a trop de bruit donc il veut
tout nous dirigeons à à à ces ces
questions essentielles et c'est la même
dans ces tout petits tableau de des
années 30 et les plus grandes de années
60 la langue c'est un peu différent mais
l'intention c'est de la même ce qui est
formidable dans cette histoire de la
culture américaine c'est qu'elle repose
en grande partie sur ce qu'on appelle
c'est un peu péjoratif les minorités
mais c'est vrai que vous prenez Francis
Bécon homosexuel vous prenez Andy warol
homosexuel tous les pains dont on
parlait tout à
l'heure la plupart d'entre eux étaient
homosexuel italiens comme John journau
et alors ce qui vous réunit évidemment
tous c'est agès c'est à cette Russie
Ukraine euh on pourrait ajouter Romain
Gary à la liste il n'est pas là mais il
vient lui aussi de Russie il est passé
par par Nice il a il a mis fin à ses
jours qu'est-ce qui s'est passé dans
cette région du monde qui fait que cette
culture russe qui se transporte en
Europe puis aux États-Unis devient une
culture
universelle parce que c'est un peu
l'histoire de votre famille aussi c'est
la c'est c'est la force et la et la
faiblesse de l'exil
c'est des populations qui sont partis
parce qu'elles étaient massacrées c'est
des populations qui étaient euh la tous
les originaires de Moldavie de bessarabi
ils étaient victimes de pogrome donc ils
sont partis ils sont partis ils sont
partis là où c'était possible de vivre
euh ils sont partis ils ont à la fois
euh embrassé le pays qui les accueillait
tout en gardant une force la force du
départ il y a une impulsion quand on
part de chez soi il y a une une douleur
mais aussi une force et je crois que
c'est ça aussi qui c'est ce mariage
cette le mariage entre le pays qui
accueille et le pays qu'on a qu'on a
quitté alors je voudrais
montrer justement les livres qui
accompagnent les trois livres dont on
vient de parler d'abord le catalogue
rotco le voici donc de la
Fondation Louis Vuitton je vais l'offrir
à agès et d'ailleurs vous avez le revers
du livre qui est absolument sublime on
voit Marc RCO sur sa chaise justement
avec deux œuvres une très et une très
sombre
agè c'est mon cadeau ah mais ça me fait
tellement plaisir merci beaucoup voà
voilà al autre cadeau alors ça c'est
pour Clément Broadway Vitas on disait
donc à propos du
222 B que le monde entier de la culture
du rock and roll on parlait tout à
l'heure de burose Alan
gberg de tous ces gens qui se
retrouvaient dans les boîtes de nuit à
New York et là il s'agit d'un joueur de
tennis Vitas de la génération m andro et
donc Florian gazon lui a consacré une
biographie c'était un type qui se
couchait jamais mais qui jou au tennis
et qui a quand même gagné un les
tournois du grand schlem personnage
inoui mort dans les conditions
particulières ça c'est le cadeau pour
Clément alors je ne sais pas quoi offrir
à Christopher je suis très ennuyé donc
Christopher c'est très simple il n'y a
qu'une seule solution je vais vous
donner les deux livres qui sont ici
celui de Clément que vous connaissez
celui d'agès vous pouvez
en échange vous donnez des r bien
évidemment mais je voudrais lire l'un
des grands poètes Quiot parce qu'on
parler des couleurs donc voici une
réédition ser de l'anglais par Pierre
levriss je voulais dire un tout petit
poème c'est un peu ridicule du type
présente des émissions littéraires mais
bon qui marchait entre le violet et le
violet c'est très rotco he qui marchait
entre les rangs variés de vert divers
allant en blanc et bleu les couleurs de
Marie parlant de choses banales ignorant
et sachant l'éternelle douleur qui s'en
allait et mélanit pas à ceux des autres
qui fitent alors des sources vives des
fontaines voilà pour ce poème donc de
tiéiot un des grands poètes de la
littérature mondiale nous avons aussi
nous terminerons avec charlesbert berant
une éducation orientale c'est chez
Casterman comme j'ai été extrêmement
long et bien je vais faire extrêmement
court c'est effectivement une éducation
orientale point B c'était au bonheur des
livres je vous recommande vraiment ces
trois livres Clément agès et donc
Christopher à propos de son père Mar
trco nous étions ravis de vous retrouver
je remercie Dony Oliven il m'a encouragé
qui présentait cette émission l'année
dernière et nousous retrouvons tout au
long de la semaine et évidemment la
semaine prochaine avec de nouveaux
livres et notamment donc des premiers
livres avec un premier livre d'un jeune
homme qui s'appelle dot vous allez voir
qu' s'appelle acide et qui va
probablement vous comment peut-on dire
non seulement vous provoquer mais vous
bouleverser Victor dumot c'est la
semaine prochaine merci d'être venu à
tous les trois on se retrouve la semaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
prochaine
Public Sénat en partenariat avec le
Centre national du livre vous a présenté
au bonheur des livres